America and the world experienced a
double shock this week with the word
that two famous names had taken their
own lives on Tuesday fashion designer
Kate Spade was found dead in her
residence here in New York and just
yesterday the body of celebrity chef and
author Anthony Bourdain was discovered
in his hotel room in France the deaths
come as the Centers for Disease Control
published a study this week showing
suicide rates in the u.s. are on the
rise in almost every state here to
discuss the issue is psychiatrist dr.
Gail Saltz author of the power of
different the link between disorder and
genius scale good morning welcome good
morning so give us some idea are there
risk factors that we can look for
because we keep saying everybody looks
so happy on the outside right absolutely
most people will have been suffering for
some period of time with depression
anxiety bipolar disorder or they're
struggling with substance abuse they've
had a history of childhood trauma
they've thought about suicide in the
past they have a family member who
committed suicide or somebody in their
community has committed suicide so if
these things are going on you really
have to be willing to talk with the
person about what might be happening
watch for changes in their behavior or
anything well so if you see someone
becoming socially more isolated
withdrawing if you see if they're
talking about being in unbearable pain
if you if you see that they're suffering
in some way they're feeling sad they're
feeling hopeless they're feeling
worthless yes then those are people you
want to be talking to you absolutely so
how do you begin that very difficult
conversation with a loved one who may be
suffering from some mental illness I
think that you say quite frankly can I
talk to you I really notice that you're
suffering or you're down or I noticed
things and I want to listen I want to be
here please tell me what you're feeling
when they start to talk about it then
you say have you thought about harming
yourself have you thought about taking
your life being really direct it is a
myth that asking about suicide will
cause someone to commit suicide you want
to ask them and then frankly if they
affirm it if they say yes I've had those
thoughts then you ask them do they have
a plan do they have a means if they do
say they have a plan or it means you
want to take that away you can save a
life by frankly removing the gun
removing the pills taking away their
method in the moment because it can be
an impulsive act and then you want to
say hey I really want to take you to get
some help
help them to find the place they can go
the therapist they can see the emergency
room they can go to and take them if
need be
are people who if you have this
difficult conversation and your
experience is someone who is considering
taking their own life willing to talk
about it to someone who may approach
them and say what's going on with you
sometimes no but most often yes it's the
feeling that they won't be understood
that they won't be listened to that
they'll be ashamed that they'll be
stigmatized if you in a very open way
maybe even say like look I've I've had
difficult times too I really understand
but mostly are listening and empathic
believe me people are very willing to
talk about it if you open that door for
them better off to ask the question than
have a regret later
dr. Gail Saltz thank you very much if
you or someone you know is in distress
the national suicide prevention hotline
is there to help it is available 24
hours a day seven days a week and it is
confidential the number is on your
screen one eight hundred two seven three
eight two five five